I'm back back for some slow games
staying away from what's today yesterday
I did a stream and I was getting in time
trouble most every game so I just joined
the hourly rapid arena play sometime in
a chess I might play some games after
this tournament finishes there's only
just over a half hour left so I might
seek some classical games but but we'll
see there is a hourly or no not hourly
but um
was it the monthly pulled bullets arena
going on I wish I was very tempted to
play it but I'm gonna try and avoid so
before I'm gonna try and play some main
lines today so if he plays next few six
I'll go into some more Lopez which is
definitely an opening I need to like
learn more b5 not so common to play like
right away
I think if blacks going for b5 so soon
then 95 is the most popular move there
but Bishop c5 okay this is a new
position for me I don't really know too
much theory here I could take on e5 this
looks very attractive or I could just
play just like castle hello Yossi Dao
how's it going
the first comment during the chat
that's 85 looks very tempting but it
might be going into like some theory
that I'm not familiar with 95 my TIGI 5d
for this bishop before check there's
also a knight 85 bishop takeoff - I'm
just going to castle here but this is
definitely a lion that all have to look
up like after the game for now I'm just
gonna play try and play normal like
positional chess well now when I take e
fives already tempting because I move
like Bishop take F 2 is met with rook
take F 2 I'm night 85 I take u 5d for
his Bishop take T 4 I mean Queen take T
4 I got the bishop paper and he has G 6
which we don't know about that
line 9 85 95 d4 bishops 84 Queen take
g-46
he's starting C 5 C 4 but the bishop
pair is a bishop air let's do it
I'm gonna just go with intuition here
I'm pretty sure he has to take oh he
takes on left - okay well I'll take with
rook yeah if I'm already Castle been
taking them F 2 shouldn't be too much of
a problem now E 4 is attacked
Perconte d 4 d 4 looks fun
because there's no time to take money
for if this light moves their z5 in the
air and if he plays my Chi for though I
have rook f1 and this light is pinned to
the f7 pawn and I would also be tight
tied down to the knight on g4 so oh this
looks nice Knight c4 that's a move I
could take this ship takes e4 pawn takes
c4 and then he five he has my t4 okay
candidate moves I could take on c4 I
could play e5 right away
I have Bishop g5 Bishop g5 might be
strongest just like keep the pressure
the first follow thank you Zork osc2
appreciate it Sanjeev just Sathya please
make a video which contain all the chess
openings at least their first 10 moves
there's a lot of openings in chess but
if you have a specific opening
recommendation let me know and I'd be
happy to try and cover it but usually
with these streams I I try and get into
a lot of different openings whoa and I
take P - I didn't even realize that pawn
was attacked that can't be a good move
all right this can't be good for plaque
okay this is a pawn sacrifice Queen f3
looks very very strong here there
anything better
there's this funny line or this funny
move queen h5 but it seems completely
unnecessary let's play Queen a3
there's also Queen Oh Queen c1 might be
more accurate Queen see while I attack
the Knights he moves back and then I
play e5 and then each six I take he
takes the bishop I take on g7 White's
winning a lot of stuff yeah I'm playing
Queen c1 because it clearly wins
material and then he 5 Queen f3 looked
very strong as well so it's turkey farm
turkey farm is referring to the position
before I played Bishop g5 I didn't play
Queen f3 there because I thought there
should be seven maybe it's still good
for whites I think this is just an
opening gone wrong for black like he he
didn't develop quickly enough he fell
into the center for trick it's in
handled correctly and now he's suffering
the consequences hey Eric what are you
up to up to today I'm doing a quick
stream I'm planning to play just a few
like rapid maybe one classical game and
then and then got get off me chess for
for several hours so enjoy it while it
lasts I think I'll just take the knight
and then yeah this is this is gonna be
some mating attack I should take up 6
Queen moves is there a force mates Queen
e1
oh there's rookie - and then Queen h6
check
this is why you you have to cast on the
open time if you leave your King in the
center bad things happen
so a game like that sometimes I would
just like move on and forget about it
but I do want to look at the opening
because there are a few interesting
points in that in that variation and I
think well I'll do I've been wanting to
do this for a while but I'm gonna just
make a new study I have so many studies
on me chess I have to start getting
organized but I'm gonna make a new study
I'll keep it public everyone sure I'll
just make it completely accessible and
we'll just call it like white openings
mmm
want to be more specific let's just say
wide opening prep and then we'll start
and then we'll just call this first one
in Spanish with early b5 and this is a
good habit for like other people to get
into especially whoever wrote the
comment that you're looking for like
improvement and opening if every game
you play you make an effort to go over
at least the opening afterwards it will
over time help you just develop a much
broader understanding of a lot of
different lines and just kind of general
chess knowledge so that's what I'll try
and do here
we'll just input the moves a lot I'm
curious about it is exactly like I
played a six early b5 I think at a high
level b5 I move forwards is considered
to be slightly dubious the only time
I've studied this line in depth was me
three or four years ago where I was
recommended it by a coach to play it for
the black side to play 95 in this
position which I know it gets very sharp
I don't Bishop take f7 to move here I
know if it's a great move
but we'll get back to that I do want to
look at Bishop c5 for a moment I'm not
sure if I can take on e5 immediately
there's not too many like GN games c3
the mainline castle and I take you guys
has been played once let's just see how
I played and then how it compares to uh
to theory so Castle you played Knight f6
and I play tonight a key five looks like
we've transpose au docks with the cheer
50 bits I appreciate it I see you play
slow chess on stream and fast chess
Austrian yeah like I've gotten feedback
from a lot of viewers and most people
prefer the streams with slow chess so I
think it's easier to follow and it's
more instructive oh and it's hero in the
chat here oh yeah oh yeah okay
hello hero so this position my TIGI v is
very low scoring for whites and it
transposed into something oh good amount
of like big names you've launched look
on on Sokolov gree shook so no one plays
Bishop take out two bishops a gift you
can't be good
cuz white just takes with the center
just have stock fish confirm yeah
White's already like crushing completely
winning actually I know just know we're
good for the night to go okay so my
tikki 5 was a plunder or a bishop take
off 2 was a blunder but Knight Iggy 5 is
a mainline and yeah this is what I was
calculating his Bishop take T 4 take and
then D 6 and I like the fact that why
had the bishop pair
but maybe blacks very fine here like box
pieces are all very good it's just ready
to come to be seven and then what is
with the scroll thing there should be
seven is coming uh c5 and c4 is a threat
and maybe blacks just doing very well
it's very comfortable
I'll have stockfish confirm oh maybe not
f4 let's do some digging
f4 96 I don't like c3 for the Queen but
I guess the Queen has to either defend
the e4 pawn or or move away to keep some
pressure
well Queen c3 okay this should be 7e
five a very high draw percentage
ninety-four Queen III I'm just playing
through the line because I'm curious if
stockfish can find any like novelty but
it seems like this has been tested at
the high level and with such a Hydra
percentage there's probably not anything
here for whites 92 okay we'll keep going
a little bit 92 take take C take b3
really it seems like such a strange
decision but most humans have played it
and stockfish recommends it why is that
so you take b3 maybe just open the C
file because it might just get traded
maybe there comes to c1 yeah position
like this obstacle our bishops
understandable why there's so many
drawers so I'll keep that in mind for
the future and
[Music]
after Bishop c5 maybe I'll just follow
the main line for next time c3 will say
make mainline and then I'm just curious
like if 906 I guess I have d4 now that's
very strong because it's a bishop of
tempo also hits the e5 pawn and if take
oh there's e5 that's very strong so the
main line would be after C 3 d6 d4 so
I'm just going through reference here or
the opening tree see take T 4 it should
be six so each three is the most-played
move but I like the stockfish
recommendation just going for the kill
with my g5 let's just see what happens
my g5 is it seems like a very direct
line 9 h6 55 57 Bishop e7 seems more
natural night a 3 or just castle white
seems pretty happy here
just good center this night's misplace
this is probably what we're all just end
the line we're like I'll just draw
arrows like white will castle might see
three on the horizon there's a Samoan
pain fish of g7 seems pretty similar
each three no just castle yeah very
similar many cases and I can come back
to f3 defend the pawn Knight c3 okay I'm
not gonna spend too much time going over
this but I think it's it's a good
practice because I haven't been doing
this too extensively lately it's like
every game just add a new opening to to
like a save study just so I can come
back to it if I ever run into it again
so Spanish early b5 um
oh that other line with with 95 maybe I
could dig into a little bit just curious
Bishop take f7 I just want to see this
this line if there's anything for white
team eise Evan what if he needs point
h5o point h5 Dino Sixers Queen e5 check
and this is just good for whites qe7
this looks really really fun like for
blitz like d4 what if d6 just my t3 it's
a good sign if like you're down apiece
foot sock fish prefers your position
okay I'll keep this in mind for the
future I might try this if I ever get it
in game anyway back to the tournament's
all of that will be saved
oh I haven't been really looking at the
chat wait what happens if black they see
five instead of 96 first real quick see
five instead of 96 Oh in that line after
[ __ ] in this position right now
Oh in this position see five first maybe
Queenie three the book is saying Queen
see three
she see five first looks somewhat
reasonable
yeah I don't know off the off the top of
my head this also looks very fine for
black queen d1 I forgot about c5
intermediate move hello chest Berra
mental I'm just curious I'm going to
just insert this game just to see what
happened if it's Yvonne check on Don's
1995 so this is some old old opening
theory I mean from one standpoint like
two bishops are nice but from another
standpoint they're not too effective
here for whites like all of Box minor
pieces have purpose in the position
Bishop g5 s e4 is pretty menacing
another ops of colored bishop position
okay fair enough
and keep the chat visible a new game I
have no ambition to win this tournament
is 15 minutes left
I'll get just one more game and then
maybe I'll play like one classical game
or maybe a few more rapid games after
this I played c5 a lot in the Spanish
and that Bishop on b3 doesn't look happy
yeah that's a Spanish bishop if the
bishop can like just stay on b3
sometimes it's happy but sometimes it
either has to like trade off or go back
to c2 of course it depends on the line
now I'm still like getting to know like
these different types of Spanish
positions it's such a vast opening I
have you're playing Spanish is white
there's so many different like weird
side lines you have to be prepared for
so it's one of the reasons why I haven't
played it too much it's because
just it's overwhelming to learn but it
is a good opening if you know it's okay
we'll stick with some sort of mainline
or not if you please Bishop c4 e6 is a
principled move I'm trying to dole the
power of the bishop and also a6 trying
b5 normally a light will play a three or
a four in this position he plays a four
and now okay the knight develops
naturally to c6 another Knight will
develop to f6 at some point I think the
plan is to play d5 you place f4 so he's
treating this like a Grand Prix which
very skeptical about I playground
Korea's whites but usually if black has
pawns on e6 and a success bishops gonna
be targeted at some point there is one
issue here like if I play tonight at six
you could play e5 right away so
ninety-seven looks normal by 97
preparing d5 yeah I don't see anything
wrong with that this would be a very bad
movement this word bughouse because I'm
nine on g6 is mate but in chess d5 is
coming
you could play e5 I only played t5
anyway uh yeah let's play d5 there's
actually an interesting line let me just
show if if he plays a five I play d5 he
takes on passant I would play Knight of
5mm recapture on g6 with the bishop
bouquet he plays e5 here which gives me
that v square and we've transposed into
some sort of French structure where this
just looks very pleasant for black
I've had these positions before coming
from the Cecilia
I'm gonna play h5 here just reinforcing
the night preventing any g4 moves a
normally black will not Castle kingside
Lux just gonna keep the center solid
maybe go for rookie eggs 92 not sure
what his plan is maybe he wants to play
C 3 and T 4 maybe even like g3 so you
really want to play Knight g3 that's
possible
ok I'm gonna throw in h4 it looks like I
might be overextending that this pawn is
very well supported and it just
restricts this Knights which now has not
too many squares to go to and long-term
plan I just want to play it like B 595
Queen b6 very enjoyable position because
it's hard for a white to come up with
much plan but maybe White has one idea
yeah the c3 g4 idea but then the
question is gonna be what next Bishop d2
okay I'm just gonna keep improving like
there's a lot of moves black and play
pretty quickly here no need to spend too
much time
Brooksie one looks like he might want to
play c4 at some point
I just realized that like d4 is now
harder to play because I have four
attackers on d4 which is a nice thing so
I'm curious like c4 looks tempting that
the discovery check but then he plays t4
and like what and c4 d 4b for nice
Bishop b1 stuff played before
immediately let's start with Bishop a6
it's like the one piece that can be
improved and now maybe I'm planning
before hitting d3 okay he plays Bishop
b1 so he wants to play does he want to
play not to say he wants to play d4 but
that's still not possible
I played before most D plans not
defended
trying to think what does he want to do
in this position
d4 I take I get away with winning upon
pretty sure I'm just gonna play a
reinforcing move g6 cuz I don't know
what he wants to do and if he has
nothing to do than g6 is just so useful
move in the position so he plays d4 Oh
hitting the night so maybe I can't win a
pawn but if I take well maybe I still
can't win a pawn taketake yeah let's
take him then calculates because I saw
this but I don't have to recapture it
away I can take with discovered check
and then maybe even take on d2 and then
win the piece so I think he he probably
misses in between
which is a bit unfortunate for him so
yeah kind of what happened there I was
just playing like improving moons and
then just kind of waiting and then
basically waiting for the blender and it
did that and I'll take on D to black
we'll just be up a piece take with the
Jeep on ya g6 was actually a useful move
if I happen to uh or if I was horse
today with a pond and defy would hang
okay so he's going for some kind of
accidental compensation but there should
not be too much cop for white here I
could take on d4 and then played Bishop
c5
yeah that looks reasonable because
there's some simple tactic that he might
miss like if he plays Mike b3o he takes
on that five well he's going crazy
this can't work can it I take he takes
on d5 I'll just say that I was expecting
like b3 and then I would skewer him but
okay I'm up to bishops should be an easy
win I really want to play h3 I get away
with it each three Queen 6565 takes e5
Bishop g2 it's probably not necessary
mmm-hmm I mean there's so many ways for
black to win here to bishops it's a lot
of bishops but what's the easiest Bishop
d7 it still looks very tempting should
be seven that's not to manage time Rick
see it's a move Bishop ease three I
won't play Bishop III but then rook c6
is kind of annoying
what do you wait what if I play h3 first
h3 he takes on c5 I take on g2 can takes
you to queen g6 check that's gotta be
good right - yeah let's do h3 I'm giving
back a bishop but I'm just going for the
kill
like right away I'm sorry I'm not really
keeping up with the chats oh yeah we're
gonna take on G - wait take on G - hang
on G - Queen g6 hang up - ripped a gage
- I know what his team to escape I could
also oh thanks for the follow Rico right
goal if I think on c5 plate Bishop b7
okay that's much simpler let's just do
that
cuz I win G - don't have a very strong
either pawn at Bishop on you - it'll
lead to some kind of meeting meeting
ideas later on
you place king g1 it's very normal to
take with bishop yeah just an endgame up
a bishop I could Castle wait can I
cancel pretty sure I can castle it's
kind of late to castle I'm not going to
Castle I'm gonna play rook h6 more
useful square for the rook I'll take
here I mean rec age six was intended to
prevent t6 the king now just some just
need some technique here bring the
bishop back idea being I want to play
rough dg8 and rip g2 and if he does that
yeah let's sack the pawn I have a
feeling there's some meaning ideas work
g4 and then like Bishop at three this
looks very close to mates I'm
threatening made into with rook take f4
and row gauge for back okay what am I
missing the chats pause the video on
Twitch actually I don't know the names
of all the openings that's why I'm a
question okay the fucsia
look at list of opening that chest hippo
it's good advice close to Celia and
Grand Prix very popular yeah yesterday
was a huge milestone at least for one of
my videos my video on the Sicilian Grand
Prix
broke 100,000 views very exciting
this guy resigns yeah I said earlier I
was gonna make an effort to take a look
at more openings-- openings closely but
I think this opening was just dubious
for whites he tried to play a Grand Prix
with a bishop on c4 but it was
committing too early this is what
happens among maybe a lesser experienced
players and if you play Sicilians black
and they played Bishop c4 too early
pause any 686 are are pretty powerful I
got a suspicion the structure was nice
had this position at this sort of
structure and many many times before
[Music]
yeah maybe I could have played
differently like in this position it's
tough you should probably throw in team
each one and then maybe you look to do
some maneuver you would like to bring
the bishop to F 2 the problem is I have
93 ideas so I don't really know what to
say well one thing I can say is there's
a very typical move here c4 which kind
of closes down the position but it might
be one of the better options slowing
that or slowing down any like Queen side
expansion with b5 anyway umm okay some
discussion about openings in the chat
mining variations will help but knowing
how to assess the position yeah
yeah if you're learning openings you you
don't want to just memorize moves you
want to understand the moves and also
like kind of have an idea of what to do
when your opponent deviates from any any
sort of theory okay we're gonna move on
oh I could go back to the tournament but
there's less than 20 seconds left so
that was a short tournament I finished
in 120 first place
I have one challenge pending from hero
for a standard game casual okay we'll
play hero one of my loyal viewers
congratulation ah ciick I see AK 25 the
first place finish how many points did
he gets not that Oh buzzer King was
working ninety-three percent of his
games okay well except hero
good luck hero you play a against the
dollar attack just like I do
okay I know hero plays a London so I
don't know what I want to do here okay
well fine I know six most flexible move
yeah Bishop f4 it's so weird like
playing with my own opens or my own
opening in this case because I have so
many different options trying to think
play c5 he'll play e3 well if I play g6
I played u6 hope maybe play Knight c3 or
maybe he'll just treat it like a normal
London Oh what's a lying okay I have a
line in mind I'll play d5 please go to
NIM self the problem with the nihms oh
is you can't play it against people who
don't want to go into it because if they
play the London if they play like
earlier Knight f3
you need another opening in your rocket
or nothing against an Enzo but it's one
of those openings that make white can
easily avoid
if he wants oh he's playing D takes d5
this is a very very trendy line which a
lot of people are playing lately
I think entertain is playing this move
when agitating plays on London I'll play
the early D takes e5 Queen D for its
Queen G for up I move most people play B
for Queen D for is in writing knight c6
well there's actually a really
complicated variation here knight c6
Bishop b5 25 check that c3 Queen take b5
might take b5 I take T 4 I don't know if
I want to calculate that also it might
just be better for whites after a pawn
to d4 Knight C sevens a threat yeah this
is very new for me if I play Queen if
I've immediately I assume the idea is to
play p4 so maybe I'm walking into some
opening prep 24 why haven't I seen this
before
I want to take too much time here but
it's an interesting position to ponder
and thank you for the follow in Curless
I c6 Bishop e5 257 we can train his
before in the end the two bishops Oh
Eagle rare just subscribed thanks for
the sub I appreciate that
okay no more looking at follows and
subscriptions I have to focus on this
position might c6 Bishop e5 Bishop g7
Bishop takes c6 Bishop takes c6 before
maybe I move like b6 there and you can
take on b6 and then Queen JP six Queens
86 pawn to e6 blacks down upon
what to do what about 96 Bishop e5
Bishop d7 and taketake be for a 5 ok
let's start with 96 can't be a bad move
I'm 25 also I play Queen a 5 and then
Bishop d7 but then he can take and then
play before and queen a 325 Oh Queen a 5
he can play b4 immediately
oh no he can't Bishop hangs 25 Knight c3
Bishop g7 Bishop takes c6 Bishop takes
c6 be for Queen a3
I really don't know I might just be
going into sums for the prep this will
be a great opening to look at afterwards
he's gonna play B forward here I mean
there's inherently slim compensation
like Black has a bishop pair this Queen
will hopefully at some point be a target
on d4 a5 these moves like a 5 and B 6
are so thematic for the position a 5 I
assumed he would play c3 we trade mm b6
is on another sub oh thank you Jeff
zero eight one six nine two I appreciate
that so many people subbing this is not
the time to get distracted a 5c3
take take wrong with a5 is it makes it
more difficult to play b6
oh he could also a 583 is Rex defendant
on anyone that's annoying what do I do
here
b6 take Queen take take take so you
three will only move
maybe I just go for like positional
compensation like we're trading queens
in this line tick tick tick tick tick
I'm in c3 because both his sheep on
Anna's a pond are somewhat backward and
I just play like they should be seven
and castle and rook c8 okay I have a
feeling objectively it might be slightly
better for whites but from a practical
standpoint it looks very playable you
are calculating so much what you doing
bullet yeah and bullet I use intuition I
mean there's a line between like
intuition and a more concrete
calculation and I'm probably I might be
overthinking this but like I'm a in a
more classical game or like tournament
style game and this is what goes through
my mind when I play chess II just have
to like look at all the variations and
make the best conclusions I can thanks
for the follow Malik or 17 well it's
good he's thinking cuz like the first
seven moves he played very quickly and
now at least there's some position which
at least were both both out of book
knowledge hopefully so okay well trade
Queens I'm expecting I'm expecting Queen
jiggly six and c3 I guess he could play
c3 immediately but that maybe I keep
Queens on the board like Queen a six and
there might be some issues for his King
plays a3 hmm interesting slightly
unexpected another follow oh thank you
Jeff
not too many people subscribe and then
follow
slightly out of order okay I have to
play quicker here the first line that's
coming to mind and thank you fuzz master
first line that's coming to mind is
Queen Daisy fortnight 84 85 just trying
to break down the queenside plot
information I don't see anything wrong
with that I don't know what he's going
to do after 85 he could take but then a3
is a weakness and one of the main points
if black manages to win back a pawn it
should just be a better position for
black just because two bishops I'm also
got a pawn structure
I didn't realize I wasn't following you
this is Jefferson oh yeah
hello Jefferson I don't think I've ever
called in Jefferson I've always called
him Jeff yeah thanks for watching and
following and subbing and yeah one of
the issues for ye but he he would like
to play c3 and just like hold everything
but there's this pin so I would just
take and went back the pawn right away
I'm a LightSquared Bishop can actually
be very strongly English it might go to
b5 in many cases and just just cut
through the position so this is a type
of position I can maybe sit back and
relax but I'm trying to put myself like
in his shoes like what is he thinking
about and what are the candidate moves
c3 doesn't look good at all the ship t2
runs into some eye problems 92 I wasn't
even looking at because I just take
there's still the pin and this pawn is
now attacked three times so yeah maybe
he was just regretting his decisions I'm
just crying
I feel like maybe he had some advantage
I think earlier a bit probably allowing
allowing Queen take D for an 85 not the
best decision I regret nothing but that
92 move maybe he didn't realize maybe he
realized he was giving back 1 pawn but
didn't realize he's losing was a three
pawns because a three is hard to defend
if I got a pawn to a three that's a
dangerous cast pawn I mean could play
Bishop yeah I was about to say he could
play Bishop c1 just such a sad move so
if I take it's just a trade
I mean Bishop e5 looks very tempting
just keep all the pressure that may be
in place Bishop b2 then we kind of have
to trade okay so where's the advantage
here for black
let's start with Bishop e5 if you place
Bishop b2 then I'll take on a3 oh then
he takes with Knights hmm then Bishop b4
check c3 I could just play like Bishop
d6 just like keep all the tension like
what is he doing here he takes on before
I trade on anyone and I take on before
at the bishop and there's a couple of
factors which just makes this position
better for black of course the two
bishops but also the pawn structure
assuming these pawns get traded be for a
pawn
then he's left with this kind of
backward C pawn which is a huge drawback
for whites given that we're heading for
some positional endgame place f3 so I'm
tempted to just buy King e7 and rook HC
it's start pressuring c2 I have a lot of
students who like in this situation they
would castle because they're taught that
like early in the game you're supposed
to castle but when Queens got traded the
King was fine staying in the center yeah
well player c8 to manage time a bit
better dream of taking on e1 actually
let's not remove that Bishop take
DeForest option rook c1 that's a good
sign is that a free pawn on each - yes
he could take on before wait a minute
okay
this is gotta be good for some reason
was all this like this should take you
to in Bishop f4 maybe but he's mighty to
my plate III know okay I'm gonna keep
all the tension and play Knight d7
because I'm in time trouble and my night
was doing nothing on that six cuz he
paid up three so I want to maneuver it
to c4 I looked at the last comic King d7
my king doesn't want to be on g7 cuz it
would block the Knights so now yeah I
think we can trade on a one then take on
before still a matter of converting the
position he's debating which piece our
pawn to move to c3 we're not going to
trade because this pieces are kind of in
the way of each other like as Bishop
does not want to be on c3 does it make
some Knights basically immovable I might
even be threatening Bishop take h2 here
so he plays g3 I'll just continue at 96
you might see four is coming
it's hard to move anything for light but
it still takes on improving for black
like my pieces are good but how I like
destroy him Bishop take e to probably
doesn't work maybe for Bishop T - hmm I
don't see an immediate kill so I'm just
gonna play like a just another like
resource in the position idea being that
I might want to play h4 and if he plays
h4 it would be king g3 sometimes in this
sort of situation you can't just rely on
one weakness
he has like one clear weakness on the
Queen side but I have to create another
weakness on the Kings side called the
principle of two weaknesses King g7 was
before Bishop d6 Oso way back when hey
thanks for the stream I'm new to chess
they're learning a lot so that's good to
hear
King King yo nice to see you
why are you not a GM I have no norms and
my rating is fellow 2400 feeding so it
takes a ton of work there's been there's
been two tournaments where I've been
close to GM norms but they're very
difficult to get it takes a huge level
of consistency okay at four
teasing move might as well drop tonight
and see four ideas of of 93 perhaps
sometimes these positions are about just
continually improving and waiting for
some blunder 93 looks attractive I don't
know if it's doing anything though you
still have to move quickly
oh I have a funny move right a 3 a 3 oh
but then he takes and plays repeat 1
maybe it doesn't work ok well if I have
6 you want still playing out of three so
a six is restricting the future in Night
Moves this is 93 and I take a four-digit
83 Rugby morning
maybe I start with Bishop a4 it's just
really building a pressure on the on the
c2 pawn and 93 might be a threat now or
maybe even by e3 because if I can attack
c2 with my bishop my knight in my rook
that's a lot of attackers I feel like
I'm playing well this game it's just an
issue of time management sometimes you
can play a good game get low on time and
then mess everything up I have to start
playing at a quicker pace
King d1 thanks for the follow whoever
you are
93 mg - wait what if just 93 right away
I need to take take review um there is
king d2 in the end oh but then I take
his night let's do it
it looks very unusual but might be
winning something
he has kingi to here but that might be
five King detune might be fine
threatening Knight takes c3 Bishop b2 it
should be for check c3 Bishop a5 thanks
for the follow
okie me show appreciate that yeah I
might as well provoke c3 in chess kudo
appreciate that I have 45 seconds left
let's just focus on this stuff it's this
board I'm expecting c3 King g3 really um
96 looks good because now his King is
actually getting attacked like my
Knights gonna be very very happy jumping
into c4 e Ford
there's a ton of like Queens pawn
openings where the knight like loves to
be on d6 in the middle game combines
very well with the deep on so key me III
is pretty much forced take tape I still
don't see a win time management
okay we'll play Bishop c3 some trades
but it should benefit black it's good
there's a two second increment maybe
that's one reason why I've been spending
so much time it's because I know there's
two second increments so if I play
quickly enough I won't like 1 c2 should
be falling very soon Knight b3 oh that's
a blunder cousin I see for coming I can
retreat right there's no danger yeah
this Bishop is defended by tactics so
that's just up a piece I know hero's a
fighter
he doesn't like to resign uh more
tactics he'll resign eventually though
the tactics keep coming he likes to get
accidental compensation when I least
expect it
I'm very curious about the opening cuz
Queens e4 is a new move for me
[Music]
there is another other line that I want
my looking at you though is that oh
that's not me but it's very close to me
very close to me the c-4 is for us and I
take stuff happens good game here oh
yeah definitely a game to learn from cuz
I felt very uncomfortable in the opening
ok people in the chat you know they got
a GM is not that easy Jim is not that
easy there's so many people who like
spend their whole life and never get to
GM or even like master for that matter
you have to devote countless hours of
like serious study for GM ok let's go
back analysis forward I might as well
make a new study because I made one
earlier for white openings you just grab
the link for this game study used to you
just call it black oh crap oh boy yeah
we'll just import this game thanks for
the follow crash zero seven zero two
three
okay so d4 flip the board I will admit
I've studied this very briefly I've had
this many times and actually mostly in
over the board blitz tournaments for
some reason I've ran into this at least
like four or five times and most people
will go into the slide after e6 before
and then a five c3
to take take and then there's a very
nice move here for a black which i think
is a novelty maybe it's been playing on
me chess let's see
oh it's been played once on me chess oh
it's been played by me on me chess yeah
okay it's I would like to call it my
novelty but it's really just sock fish's
first choice Bishop t7 which I think it
it's a really pleasant line for black
because it solves most of the problems
that black faces in this line
the idea is black wants to play b6 but I
think these six runs into Bishop yeah
Bishop take P 8-bit should be five check
which is crushing for light right
taketake it should be if I check and
then c6 is coming
Keeney seven can't be can't be good for
black so so this is a position I've had
many many times before or a handful of
times before
feels like many times in this line where
a black wants to play p6 next and then
it's actually a very pleasant like black
will play b6 almost no matter what white
does then black at least equalizes in
this game hero played Queen d4
oh this follows a famous crew 64 game
maybe I should go back and look at that
game wait yeah cuz what did crew 64 do
he played 903 I play b6 he gave back the
font yeah okay I have a vague memory of
playing this game
oh thanks for the cheer from hero one
hundred bits appreciate that yeah I
think every time I play hero I beat him
and then he gives me a hundred bits so I
just have to keep playing him and
meeting him that's nice
uh yeah I think this is this was a very
reasonable position for black and this
is one of the reasons why I am making an
effort to like take openings more
seriously especially in these online
blitz games even bullet games because I
don't want to be losing to consistently
to crew 64
what's the valuation here is it just
equal blocks a little bit better locks a
bit better Knight c3 that blocks the
spreader like there's one plot island
this pot is more weak than it is strong
the half-open a file is nice for black
ok so let's look at the screen d4 move
has it been played before hold up we got
one draw wait I drew here oh no I draw
him
oh we drew in that ad um endgame where I
was completely winning and then I got
too careless that is true
I've already suppressed that from my
memory
I apologize for forgetting that ok Queen
d4 no games Queen d4 is a novelty it's
been playing oh it's been played by no
joke shout-out to no joke for like
winning to no joke win the only game
ever played in this position
maybe he played Queen d4 cuz he was just
out of book and like he was just making
something up it's not really any
preparation but it's an interesting idea
so I played knight c6 Bishop b5 yeah
why is oh okay I hover over the move it
shows arrow Bishop g7 Bishop takes c6 so
we followed some mainline
I think White has to play b4 here white
doesn't play before it is Queen and five
check oh wait no then then he has before
oh so mind if three looks reasonable
because when a if I check maybe there's
a sign before Queen a 30.8 six even I
don't know before b6 take take so maybe
before is a slight inaccuracy you should
only play before when it's necessary for
some reason I thought before his only
move maybe he was listening to the
stream heard me say before who was like
expected and then played it button I
thought three maybe just stronger
because it is hard to win back this pawn
if I play 94 then he is before and maybe
it's just a different line okay um what
happened in the game somehow it turned
out really good for black wait 903 isn't
good because of Bishop b5 it should be
fine
Bishop e5 looks wrong but why does it
look on maybe a 4 and then at Bishop a
Sixers before this looks scary for about
what's going on this should be fine
a 4 no this can't be good for black okay
let's see what happened the game just
take take be 46 I was actually already
feeling somewhat comfortable here like
if we go into this end game and he plays
c3 I was just gonna slow play I was just
gonna play like Bishop e7
oh maybe King g7 inside the castle and
then Rick c1 I thought there was some
long-term compensation for black its to
open files but after a 3 yeah this is
already looking suspicious I think he
had to take but then at some point I'll
scoop up a 3 and then get a similar
maybe somewhat similar situation to what
happened in the game yeah let's go back
I want to use stock fishing I don't see
if it comes up with any ideas
after King g4 so knight c6 top move
if it's giving Bloxom advantage that's a
very good sign
ooh 97 I didn't even consider 97 what is
97 be for already take them in before
Bishop e7 wait once okay a 5c3 Bishop e7
ah Bishop f6 coming that's a really
interesting idea
97 allowing Bishop e7 Bishop f6 that
demon-like didn't even come to mind
and if light takes and light will suffer
from this line Queen g3 I assume a take
before what Bishop a6 why not a take
before
oh there's Bishop c7 so Bishop a6 first
black stone blocks down to pawns but
this is massive compensation is all this
pressure Y squared Bishop is a monster
he five is a threat okay if we go back
so that's just a good line for [ __ ] 97
good to know and what if before right
away same thing
what oh but uh the knight is one king
before would hang the Queen uh okay well
that's good to know and let's see what I
did in the game was that any good 57
take take before b6
yeah I was expecting this to be maybe
just equal maybe even slightly better
for whites but yeah this line
maybe I was under estimating box
potential here his position just look
good for black okay oh so he played the
best move he played eight three no I
took him played in five and yeah he just
had to take okay well good game hero
that was that was a quick stream I'm
gonna end it there have some interesting
games some decent quality chests
hopefully people learn something and
yeah I will be back I'll be back
tomorrow like tomorrow around the same
time for another stream so thanks
everyone for watching and I will see you
guys in the future bye